this show is brought to you by tracker
that's tracker never lose anything again
with tracker listeners to this show get
a special discount of 40 off of your
first tracker device this isn't an offer
everywhere it's only for our listeners
go to the tracker.com and enter promo
code Church to get 40 off of your first
tracker device that's the tracker.com
and use promo code Church
show is also brought to you by the
wonderful people at NatureBox say
goodbye to weird and mystery ingredients
and start snacking confidently with
NatureBox they have delicious snacks
they're they're very nutritious they're
delicious go to naturebox.com Joey to
get 50 off of your first box now that's
right go to naturebox.com Joey to get
half off that's 50 off of your first box
now show is also brought to you by
onnit.com use code word church to get 10
off all of their great optimization
products like Alpha Brain new mood
shroom Tech immune and dream Tech sport
use code word search to get 10 off
old school [__] suckers
foreign
kick this horse kick it Lee kick it
this goes back to 1971
I read the [__] Franklin
[Music]
there you go [__] here we go
here we go
oh [__]
listen to Aretha [__]
zero [__]
[__]
are you [__] kidding me
this is what black people were [__]
black people listen to those [__]
horns they don't give a [__] they're
[__] right with everything it's over
the Church of What's Happening Now
Wednesday the 23rd of March what's
happened you bad [__] it's
myself and my main [__] Lee Syed
in the house cute little blue [__]
shirt on I gotta look cute for you all
the time smoking and [__] look at you
all you need is a little Penguin on your
shirt I can never I never had like the
actual polo shirts they made a line in
there that I thought of you nature box
are you sick and tired of mystery
that's Lee's favorite [__] line I
can't win he loves mystery ingredients
even when I'm trying to be good so it's
like today for lunch I was like okay I
don't have I I tried to do meal prep I
bought like enough food for three days
but I I didn't have time to go to the
store I was like okay I'll go to Denny's
and I'll get a salad before I go to work
I was there for 20 minutes
it was a ten dollar salad and they
finally brought it out and it looked
like were you there to go you have to go
no I don't need to stay at Denny's what
kind of salad did you get guys I got a
grilled chicken salad that's all I got
and it looked like
like the homeless guy up front who was
begging for money it was his salad it
was the salad it was brown it wasn't
even like put together at all it was
just like they just threw lettuce and a
little bit of avocado and chicken and
whatever else in the bowl
and I was about to turn around and just
eat it and like you know when you have a
lunch and you're just disappointed and
it's just crappy and just pissed off but
I was like no I turned around I was like
hey this is a ten dollar salad I don't
want any of this so they gave me a
refund and I walked over to the Mexican
place across the street and I got a a
grilled chicken plate with some beans
and rice I know the rice is how was it
delicious but the thing that they have
over there that you turned me on to in
Hollywood that juice place they have
over there so I had something with like
orange strawberry papaya [__] honey
yogurt it was delicious I almost went to
the juice place today you should oh it's
so good I almost went to the juice place
in Hollywood whenever I go give a blood
test that's my reward oh yeah you have
to that's right the juice place and I
get a chicken salad on wheat with the
[__] avocado delicious there the
Lucha I've been going to that [__]
place for 20 years you know that
they started out on Vine
no yes they started on a [__] Vine in
a little parking lot it was like the the
valet Shack for a parking lot that's
what they started did they even have a
place to sit down no you they had tables
outside like little boots outside I love
that you parked it had no it had no
Ambiance but it didn't have Ambience but
we gave it Ambiance was that it didn't
have ambiance right they were all
Spanish women they made four or five
sandwiches then and 20 million juices
and I'd go in there for the honey milk
and strawberry they have so many of the
red the pink Cloud okay strawberry milk
and a dash of honey they have a lot of
different juices there you know she goes
back to the holidays for a month the two
girls have been running that store
for 20 years been the same employees
same chick same uh owner it's it's it's
a phenomenal place when they started
building the mall on Vine on whatever
that [__] street is on there they had
a move
and they were forced to move so what
they did was they put up signs saying
that we gotten forced to move they're
giving us some settlement we'd like to
find the place close by
like 20 places reached out they gave
them like a good rent just to have them
in there because it's been a
neighborhood staple for 20 years that's
amazing they were probably there 10
years before I got there and I've been
going there for 20.
I've been going there for 19.
so I discovered them like the third day
in [__] Hollywood
and it's great in Hollywood it seems
like a lot of places raise their prices
just because it's so expensive to be
here
a juice is four dollars it's 8.50 for
the sandwich and the [__] juice they
have a lunchtime special and a bag of
chips I never get the chips because I'm
full from the chicken salad on whole
grain with the [__] fresh avocado and
the and the Juice by the way they always
give you the whole picture they give you
the whole blender okay so you have two
[__] these are real people these
aren't these [__] Gentile corporate
with and they cut the fruit in front of
you you see them this isn't like [__]
uh you know those frozen things that you
got Jamba Juice whatever the [__] that
is that nuclear flute that you think
you're eating not healthy and it's just
[__] sugar do you ever do the uh like
the Mexican fruit stands on the side of
the road where they cut it up always uh
always I go in I get the fruit but you
can't let them put the chilies I can't
do it I tell them not to put them in I
don't like the white stuff but if you're
in a bind and you're traveling around
L.A and you're hungry just to hold you
over a bag of fruit from those things
for four dollars and they chop it up for
you and it's all fresh I had them do
because it like like a mango because
they do mango [__] delicious but they
have like like lime juice and all the
pepper and stuff that I don't like so I
had them do orange and pineapple I just
had that I just was eating that all that
was delicious people say you know it's
got the fruit the sugar you know what
man I lost a lot of [__] I'm waiting
fruit so
whatever whatever you know what I'm
saying but I'm happy
the last [__] nine days have been
death
like it went from being super busy guys
I don't know what to see a lot of people
I have to describe what we go through
sometimes
it went from me leaving the house you
remember like every day for two weeks I
left the house at nine eight thirty
seven fifteen to go to a 10 o'clock
meeting because you got to leave two
hours early in the morning yeah at least
I usually do is I have like a protein
shake I get in the corn I get the [__]
out of Dodge I get over the hill
I get down and I eat breakfast and then
I go to my meeting so you know I'm
saying like but next week I have
meetings at four and [__] like that the
last nine days
have been death
so I've been writing but no comedy
writing but I do little things you know
I'm saying like I sent my first [__]
uh thing to Gordon so at least I got one
of the chapters out of the way which
I've been going over now I'm writing the
intro to the [__] book so little by
little we're putting this book together
now it's coming together I don't have a
lot of dates in the sum a lot of people
mad at me because I'm not going a lot of
places I usually go I had to cut my
schedule in half this year guys because
I have a lot of things going on here
plus I wanted to keep working on the
podcast we got the new studio so please
understand me that these come around
once 2017 I will do all those cities I'm
not doing this year whether it's
Minneapolis or or Utah or it'll be a
better show too don't you think it'll be
a better show listen man I hate what
they do because they want to book every
12 to 11 months I can't write that fast
and lately it's been like you know
you're going to [__] writing slumps
and what happens is it's like being a
Salesman okay when you
when you're a Salesman I come talk
delete
so if I talk to 10 people
and I'm selling vacuums okay okay
one person might buy that day
but
three people are gonna buy but they're
gonna talk to the significant other
well they're waiting for a check or
they're waiting for the tax return or
they're you know what I'm saying so you
make these sales now you just follow up
with them tell them about your deals and
your specials the same thing happens
when you write calmly
you have 15 or 16 things you're thrown
out there
you know and you wait till one of them
bites and then you write following them
and meanwhile you're still trying
different bits and shit's not working so
you're just getting rid of stuff and
then you visit again in some night it's
a Thursday night I just get to town let
me visit again and if it doesn't work in
front of a real crowd I get the [__] rid
of it lately I've been getting rid of
everything
So eventually I'm gonna get three bits
I'm gonna bind into and then I build an
hour and then it becomes excitement
again you said for the last two weeks
you haven't really been doing any comedy
writing are you actively not doing that
or do you not have anything you want to
write right now no I've been not comedy
writing and the sense of taking a joke
and writing it out okay comedy writing
in the sense of
getting up at five like I did today
before I had to leave at seven and
writing for two hours just a little nuts
and this morning I got some good [__]
you know I'm trying to get stuff that's
personal to me when I talk about topical
[__] I don't like it no more I'd rather
talk about personal [__] to me and how I
learned the thing from it we all laugh
so that's what I'm trying to put
together so you just have little Flyers
and all of a sudden one of them really
catches fire and one of another catches
fire and all of a sudden you go from
having nothing to having 40 minutes
and now you elaborated on more you put
it out there on the road and it grows
into something
okay that's interesting
so that's what usually happens right
it's just you just keep putting stuff
out there
and all of a sudden one catch is a
bigger fire than the other one the other
one's good but not what you think it
would be and then you twist it around
and you bring it out there again and
that's why I try to go to Flappers in
The Comedy Store and then
when I'm home just uh last night I
[__] passed the [__] out so yeah oh
my God I was wiped out yesterday
is it because you like sometimes we'll
go to a show and you'll tell me after
that oh I didn't think that was that
great even though for me sitting in the
back you were getting laughs and it
seemed like it was going well so when
you say like if something works it
doesn't work is it based off of just
what you think because you can get
laughs and think you have a terrible I
know I know what I'm listening for I
know exactly what I'm listening for is
it the sound of the laugh it's something
about the laugh
it's a weird laugh it's got to be a
little shocking and then laughing at it
because it happened to them
I love that kind like that's why a lot
of specials are so disappointing for me
is because I'll laugh I'll giggle but
there's like there's one I just showed
Paula
it's uh I think it's Bill Burr's first
or second it's the orange one in the
background hilarious where it's just you
don't stop you don't stop like
hysterically last hysterical it's like a
machine gun yep and that's and that's
what I like so much about about your
sets and and Comics but it's just
even though you do stories that's why I
like the store sometimes and you're like
the one person that I enjoy the store
for because otherwise I prefer an hour
and I still like you for an hour but
there's something about because with 20
minutes you usually just go crazy I go
crazy I [__] love it
I like listen if I do 45 minutes and I
have a stroke the next day will you
really you can't do it not like that
like that 45 not to stay on them and
stay on top of them like that that stuff
the store because
I I got my ass kicked so much in there
I learned that when you go up at the
store you got to go up with both guns so
that's where that comes from like my
fear
fear is a [__] you know that at 53
this morning
I was stalling to drive down there to
draw blood
like I kept talking to them I was like
don't you have to leave is this the same
appointment that you've had for like two
months yeah the six weeks
every week you were like I have to do a
job once I get in there it's cool like
he's [__] cool as [__] we talk he
talks to me he told me to stop at the
airport in Chicago where to go and get a
[__] uh hot beef sandwich at this one
at the airport Chicago your doctor's
telling you where to get a heartbeat oh
yeah he's a big [__] he's a
badass dude and then uh you know I went
down there whenever I get blood taken
out there's little obstacles in front of
myself every week okay so I have a
notebook and I have Monday through
through Sunday and then I have my
schedule but on the upper right hand
side in that little corner that little
box I have my obstacles for the week
[__] that I [__] hate doing
what I gotta do
like sitting down and writing like going
and giving blood like uh
calling somebody who owes me money
all that type of [__] goes in that box
in the top how many boxes do you have on
your on your book in your notebook like
each page like how many little sections
do you have I have just a section of
Monday through Friday okay and then like
the first thing on the goal sheet is
right two hours a day
and then you'll have any appointments
from 9 to 12 early and then usually I
just put BJJ 12 o'clock just because it
ain't nothing going on I'm going to BJJ
and then I usually have a one o'clock or
3 30 phone call
and then I'll put eight o'clock to
podcast 10 30 Comedy Store anything that
has a comedy thing I put an Asterix next
to the day
when I wake up in the morning I want to
remember I'm doing a set that night I'm
getting old
so that means I have a set so at the end
it'll be gonna count how many sets I
have and then on the upper right hand
side right there and every notebook
there's a little box
and the letters there sometimes you put
I put the calls I have to make
but now what I'm doing is I'm putting
the call today
so I don't [__] around I used to put
calls and just go I got to call Lee I
got to call Sarah I got to call Marty I
got to call Jimmy I gotta call T I got
to call me I gotta call Johnny no no now
I put it under the damn call them so
there's no misunderstandings
I have a phone call schedule
so you have to even have a [__] phone
call schedule I'm a comic but I'm a
Salesman and I'm representing myself
because this is the only way to [__]
do it
you know Cassius Morris is calling in
today right and there's nobody in this
planet I admire more than this young man
because what he's doing at his age
people listen to the podcast I'm gonna
hear them insult nobody ain't nobody
doing dick like this [__] young man
and he's been doing it for like I think
six years okay and he's getting the
education of a [__] lifetime he's
getting lifetime education
before he's 18 years old
and I was telling my agent the other day
because it's NCAA time
right in March Madness okay I don't know
if I ever told you guys this let me tell
you how crazy I've been all my life okay
so I got involved in basketball at the
age of seventh grade sixth grade I was
[__] horrifically bad
the first time I did seventh grade
basketball I went we went all in nine I
was terrible terrible terrible
and I was so embarrassed from seeing so
bad and from getting left back in the
seventh grade that besides karate I
dedicated myself to basketball
and I wanted to turn that program around
so the second seventh grade year we went
like four and three all right my dummy
year when I made my comeback I know I
was laughing but I can't I know I don't
give a [__] hey I'm a [__] [__] it
happens and you accept it for whatever
hey you were getting [__] in seventh
grade no I didn't get [__] I was dry
humping her that's what's sad I got left
back over [__] dry humping a [__] to
a pair of [__] pants that's what's
embarrassing we're all [__] jerk offs
I'm the king of the [__] jerk or
something at that age so I get left back
so now that you gotta go four and three
but I get I fall in love with [__]
basketball
right so they tell me to get really good
you have to concentrate your training
and go to basketball camps okay so one
of the first basketball camps I go to is
Willis Reed
excuse me and when I go to Real Estate
basketball camp
I meet a coach there
I forget what his [__] name was he
was from like a high school how old are
you so you were in the seventh grade
still I was in the seventh grade going
into the eighth grade when I cough why
do you close your eyes do you think I'm
gonna spit nine balls or something
what's wrong I didn't even know I did
that so
I meet this guy and he's telling me all
these things that you when you go to
camps you have to be ready because
college coaches come and they give
seminars and they talk to people but in
reality I always knew that if you're
under a junior in college they can't a
high school they can't talk it's against
NCAA violations for a coach to talk to
you if you're a junior or none oh [__]
even though you're [__] killing in
the eighth grade
I can't really say much I come up there
and say good game you have a future son
you know what I'm saying and keep you in
mind but I can't come and start [__]
recruiting you that's against NCAA we
can't even talk about recruitment about
going to your school or nothing that's
crazy I didn't know that so my second
basketball camp which was booze
basketball camp I met a coach by the
name of Tom pandas I forget where the
[__] he was then now I think he's in
Texas so he may have retired
Tom pandas I became a pen pal with I
would humiliate him I would write him
letters until he turned purple come see
me I'm tearing it up in the eighth grade
I wasn't doing dick you know what I'm
saying but in my mind I was Johnny
[__] United
but I started doing this to every coach
every time I go to a camp I get coaches
[__] whatever and I start sending
them propaganda whether it was Bill
Foster from Duke at the time where it
was the guy the guy from North Carolina
take us through a letter like what would
the letter sound like
good morning coach
I hope you're having a great day my name
is Joey Diaz I'm an 8th grader from
North Bergen New Jersey and basketball
is my life
I just want to tell you I admire your
[__] team the mailman wouldn't
deliver them no more I didn't give a
[__] when I was a kid I was a Savage
so that me being a comic never developed
at a young age me wanted to do TV never
was a young age me being a Salesman
Savage
was me at a young age like I already had
that Savvy mind that you had to reach
out to people and let them know what the
[__] was crackalackin
Jesus and then so how many packets did
you get like 10 or 12 or
I would send them
once I sent them to college coaches that
I knew then I just started sending them
to [__] college coaches everywhere
and we're in UCLA to USC any basketball
program I had watched on television
North Carolina State
North Carolina Charlotte uh
University of New Mexico was a great
College then they had cheese cheese
Johnson who covered [__] Larry Bird
in college as [__] he was one of my
counselors in Camp uh you know I just
wrote letters to colleges and would you
do this with like your friends or were
you doing it by yourself by myself at
night where what or no I was doing it in
my [__] bedroom I was always like
actual workout it wasn't like a drill oh
the drills yeah yeah at both places I
was doing because they had drills that
you did some drills I did on the
basketball court like layup drills and
shooting drills and Sprint drills and
defense drills but some drills I did at
home which was just like setups or
push-ups or jumping as high as I could
for 30 minutes or sitting against the
wall with a chair to get my defenses
legs and whatever to get your legs
strong I did everything I [__] could
man which would which would be worse for
you do you think taking away comedy now
or taking away basketball then
it was two different things because I
make a living from Comedy okay that's
true okay but it just seems like you
were like taking basketball away from me
then was one of the
biggest disappointments in my life I
never really recovered from that
I could tell because when I watch
basketball I still get kind of emotional
especially Hennessy double a ball I told
you what happened the other night when
the NCAA came on
and I was watching this my wife was
sitting there my daughter was in the
kitchen
and I was like you know
I wish
that she gets at an early age
I wish that she got it like I got it
but I wish that she got
to me
being a professional basketball player
is great and being a professional
football player is great
but Jesus Christ nothing gets my dick
harder than the NCAA Championship in any
sport
because you're playing
for you I mean yeah after a while you're
playing to get drafted
but when you talk like have you ever
watched the 30 for 30 with the NCAA guys
from North Carolina State they all get
together for a drink oh no I I never got
into college basketball but it sounds
great College
athletics man is something and now
they're trying to tax and all this [__]
but you gotta understand the
entertainment it brought to people and
it brings to like to me it it gave me
something it gave me a belief it gave me
a belief that I could do something good
enough and get a scholarship to go to
one of these colleges that's the bottom
[__] line if you really want to go to
college and you want a [__]
scholarship
to do whether you want to be a football
player or a basketball player whatever
when I saw
Mike o'conn ah
Michael corn was a kid from Jersey City
it was an Irish kid who went to a school
called Hudson Catholic and he was six
foot seven
and he was six foot seven he was white
and he was poor he never had a frog and
he had a mother who worked in a diner to
support him
and like in the eighth of his freshman
year he hurt his knee and he had to wear
a bracelet a brace in high school
and he would play basketball basketball
and the braces he played so much
basketball through the braces started
going into his skin but it didn't matter
he took Hudson Catholic to a [__]
final the finals having a kid named
Jimmy spinarco Jimmy spinarco ended up
going to Duke
and this [__] ended up going
North Carolina
oh no way okay so way before the hurleys
New Jersey City went to Duke
the kid who opened up that connection
was a kid by the name of Jimmy spinarco
from Hudson Catholic now in Jersey City
you had powerhouses Hudson Catholic and
Saint Anthony's Saint Anthony's is the
one you see every year in the high
school Bobby Hurley
you know Bobby Hurley and Frankie Edgar
the same person
if you know anything they both hustle
they both [__] died for what they did
it's amazing so
uh
what the [__] are we talking about here
college basketball college basketball so
I'm saying that to me one of the
greatest things
one of the first things I ever saw
that let me know I could do something
with my life was on a Monday night
an NCAA finals when Marquette played
North Carolina
and in that in that bracket in that
bracket something happened to one of the
forwards from North Carolina and Michael
corn had to fill it
in the final four my friend which is one
of the biggest Platforms in the United
States year after year
this has to be one of the biggest
sporting events this white [__]
Irish kid from Jersey skit City
scored 31 points as a freshman but not
only that the guy who was covered him
was Glenn ganjazak who went on to play
for the New York Knicks a white dude six
foot four forward who always had a
couple of serving and [__] like this
this guy was a defensive white Savage
from Boulder years later he tried to
shoot himself in the heart with a 22.
that's a complete different story Jesus
Christ and he missed how the [__] you've
been playing basketball for 20 years
sinking 20 Footers and all of a sudden
you try to shoot yourself in the heart
with a 22 and you miss what the [__]
what what the [__] goes on here
what's the mega long story short this
white Irish [__] scored 30
something points as a replacement as a
freshman as a freshman but he always
gets better
I just sit down on Monday night to see
what happens it's Jerry Maguire's last
of the game as a coach for Marquette and
North Carolina has to play him go look
it up okay North Carolina Marquette what
was the final score
what year was it
[__] it's got to be 77.76 sorry about
this guys my allergies are on fire today
I'm dealing with [__] uh you know I had
to go I'm going to the doctor Monday at
2 45 for the nose doctor
to figure out if this is allergies do I
need the surgery it's the [__] Afrin
you know the afren's [__] me up
completely I think the whole game is on
YouTube
oh if you want click on the game but
give me the sport the score you want the
box score yeah the box score was what
okay
so a 6759 Marquette one Marquette won
because
the coaches it was the coach's last game
and they won for him great team Jerome
Whitehead Butch Lee [__] bad
[__] out of Marquette and they
play against North Carolina
and they beat North Carolina but it
didn't matter it didn't matter to me
something happened to me that let me
know as a human being at that age what
year was that 77
at the age of [__]
14. something happened that night that
let me know
that I could do something in my life
when they said and I'm starting forward
for North Carolina
okay starting forward for North Carolina
Mike o'corn from Jersey City New Jersey
no I said starting forward from North
Carolina from Jersey City
Michael card
I can't tell you
I can't I was just overwhelmed like my
body broke down
like I was gonna [__] my pants like just
everything in the world and I knew right
there I wanted that for me I knew that I
wanted to be on that stage someday not
comedy-wise and not as a television guy
not even close
just
in the finals of the NCAA so when you
were writing those letters you believed
I [__] believed I started when I saw
that I believed that I could get out of
my situation which wasn't at that time
wasn't a bad situation but I believe
that I could get myself into North
Carolina that I didn't have to be a
burden on my mother I really [__]
believe that guys
forgive me if you said it um but do you
know Michael corner just the fact that
he was from Jersey City
years later I met him and explained to
him what had happened and he looked at
me and like [__] swelled up because
he knew
you know he didn't have a father growing
up
you know his mother worked at a [__]
restaurant as a waitress and she saved
her tips to buy him [__] in those
days it wasn't Nike sneakers it was a
sneaker by the name of ponies
so if you didn't have Julius Irving's
limousines for the feet you had to have
ponies do they have that game on YouTube
can you put the beginning real quick to
see if they say it before my man calls
in would it be a problem no well I'll
just um
but that's that's what gave me that
right there let me knew right there with
my life that I could do something
and that's all I wanted to do at that
time that was it
I knew that that's what I [__] wanted
to do no I think they start at the tip
off do they do the lineup after that or
no no I do a tip they do well show the
tip off I'll show you what this [__]
guy looked like he was a skinny white
dude with bad [__] skin but looking
at him you can tell this [__]
was dangerous and look who it is it's my
childhood friend on the phone Sabatino
listen I'm doing a radio show can I call
you when I get out of here I'm telling
these [__] about Michael coren
at North Carolina when he was a freshman
these [__] don't know I'll call
you back Sabbath I love you
and Mickey and Jackie galoon are you
please [__] don't know I'll
call you backstabs I love you cocksucka
all right I'll show you who this guy is
go ahead and start this [__] you
see 31 right there he was all over the
place look look you look you're watching
he was right there right from the tip
look at 31. the baby blue suit on you
see 31 that was my idol right there that
white dude would [__] you up basketball
wise this was a kid from Rocky Mountain
North Carolina that black kid
was a bad [__] right there this
was a great
question
[Applause]
[__] Walter Davis went on to play for
the Phoenix Suns and he was a looking
looking for it look at this [__] right
here [__] suckers
yeah this is my shoe you can turn it off
this was my [__] this was my what got my
dick hard and I didn't stop after this
this was it this was for me like reading
uh
ladies and gentlemen Lenny Bruce like it
just I I nearly I couldn't believe it no
more I couldn't [__] stop
but that was my inspiration right there
I'm watching that kid them say his name
from Jersey City New Jersey because I
was from North Bergen right next door at
that point did you know that he was
gonna be playing or it was a surprise
you were just watching the game as a fan
I found out mid-season that there was a
kid from Jersey City playing
I always wondered what had happened to
that kid
you know when I was a kid I read the
papers I delivered papers and I used to
read the paper about these kids in
Jersey City
first of all had a 4.0 average back then
like he became like a big time attorney
he played for the Sixers for like a year
but he was too white and too small you
know he was six foot two it doesn't
happen we had another kid his name was
Jackie he was a white kid from the
jerseys from West New York New Jersey
which is all Cuban but he was a white
dude he he went to he grew he went to
school really saw his wife to school
Memorial High School oh cool Jackie
galloon was another bad [__] was
six foot one who his claimed to fame was
playing basketball on national TV on a
hit acid he ended up going to South
Carolina he did not play it yes he did
but he this little white scrawny dude
from Memorial ate up Butch Lee that
black dude from Marquette yeah he ate
him up on national television and that
was his claim to fame whenever I'd see
Jack galoney a dog you know what I mean
I end up [__] Butch Lee on that on TV
he didn't go make it the pros because he
was too short and [__] but you didn't
see there was two dribblers I remember
growing up a [__] Pistol Pete
Maravich and B jacking alone when I say
dribble I mean you know no I know what
you mean what are you giggling for like
because he played an NBA game or a
college whatever it is on acid
that was his clay but he never told
nobody like the baseball player only the
[__] inside is new like we knew his
kids that that was because he'd always
be on asking on the courts
that he is that he is
[__] what's up oh [__] look at you
what's happening guys what's up Cassius
Morris I love the [__] room thanks
man kiss all over the place in the
church oh [__] that's my dog what's
going on in your world oh man nothing
nothing but good stuff lately uh it's
been wonderful how about you same [__]
here just watching you doing stuff so
what are you doing over at Rick
Bronson's
um I met Rick just over a year ago now
at a Bert Chrysler show and I introduced
myself and I asked him to do my podcast
uh we did it next thing you know
um I was at the club more and more often
and uh Miss Pat actually helped me get a
job there
so what do you do over there
I'm a door guy and I uh run the sound
booth as well do you really how many
nights a week
uh about three four nights a week and I
get a lot of weekends I've got to work
with Ari Sam Tripoli Bert it's been
beautiful
[__] if I had a warrant if I didn't have
a warrant I'd be up there with you
smoking Bazookas the whole [__] thing
you know what I'm saying corrupt hey
anytime we actually we have a new
picture of you in the club now I've been
waiting for you to come up here good
how's your family doing they're doing
great how's your sister she's good she's
uh ninth 10th grade something like that
just had her birthday my mother's
birthday is today what so what did you
guys do today you go to like Olive
Garden or something like that yeah extra
breadsticks you know all right
so what concerts have you been going to
lately
I've been to so many and I was watching
the Periscope that you guys were doing
earlier obviously about Black Sabbath I
just saw them twice and when I said to
you that iomi and Ozzy almost made me
like emotional a couple times I wasn't
joking I mean
it's it was absolutely incredible I only
did like a 10 minute solo during dirty
women
couldn't believe it I was at Slayer
Alice Cooper Motley Crue all your old
stuff that you and you go to all these
shows
um a lot of the time I'll buy a ticket
if I'm a huge fan otherwise I'll just
get a press pass and they'll just send
me in there through the back with a
little pass and a ticket so I can stay
in there and I've been dabbling with the
photography so it's not that easy though
how do you get the press pass it's not
like they're handing them out
I don't know I mean I just applied and
they I think that there's somebody at
the company it's it's the the number one
concert company in Canada they just
decided to give me a shot luckily and
they they obviously have have taken a
liking to me which I'm very grateful for
so I mean you always need that one
person especially when you're in a
position like mine on the come up that
will you know give you that shot
Cassius where do you get this uh thing
that you have
do you get it from your mom do you get
it from your dad I mean
you're way ahead of the [__] curve
you're way ahead of the curve what
you're doing now listen how much of a
loser I am I was doing a 30 I was a
sound guy out of [__] Comedy Club
checking IDs and then I got promoted to
the bar back right you're doing it how
old
uh 17 now and you're going to college
and everything you have plans to go to
college I mean what are you doing at
some point I'll take a couple courses
yeah definitely you're not going right
after high school no no you're taking a
year off yeah definitely I'm proud of
you that's a good choice right there
number one what made you decide on that
I mean it happened recently I just
figured that instead of sitting in a
classroom talking to people about
running a soundboard talking to people
about photography I would actually
benefit more from doing photography and
running a soundboard and running a light
show and you know making these
Connections in the real world you know
not sitting in a class
with a shitty little computer actually
you know doing these things and and
putting myself in a position where I can
get employed for doing these things just
based on you know experience
again where do you [__] get this
Savvy from your mom your dad I mean
what the [__] are they thinking like
this the day will drooling on themselves
like when we get this kid from
I just I've been inspired what can I
tell you I was inspired by by you guys I
was inspired by Corolla and Rogan and
all that camp and it's just something
that when I discovered it it was
something I knew I really wanted to do
now when you told them about the no
College was there any resentment was
there any anger was there any yelling no
not at all they're fully supportive yeah
Jesus Christ you're [__] lucky God
bless you Cassius
yeah are you coming are you coming here
Cassius are you coming to LA or what's
the plan I was planning on going there
this past summer but I got a a media job
up in BC that I had to get to but um I'm
actually might be up there in September
and I might actually because I just saw
Sabbath twice and if it just wasn't
enough I might time it around the
Hollywood Bowl show so you know
September 19th show right is that the
date are there still tickets left
there should be you could probably get
some no and I was saying like where are
you gonna work like you should just move
here when you're 18. like there's no
reason not to you have what six seven
years now experience
those six seven I think it's coming up
on eight now I mean it's it's been
pretty crazy but that's definitely the
plan I feel like La is just kind of
calling my name at this point I'm just
waiting for the right circumstances you
know what is the what is in your sights
right now what are you looking to do
right now cash is like what is it that
you want to do if you move to L.A what
is the ideal job
I think some form of television or radio
hosting I mean definitely if I could
take the podcast and take it obviously
it probably at this point wouldn't go to
this level but take it to a level like
corolla's taking it to that would be my
dream job definitely and I I want to
keep pursuing this photography I want to
have something on maybe TV uh by dabble
in acting as well uh if it's in the
entertainment industry I'm happy
basically
good for you man
I mean you want to work it serious as a
radio host would you think just to
transfer your podcast down here and bang
it out and get some sponsors and really
go for it five days a week and interview
or musicians and all the stuff you want
to do is that what you're looking at
right now
yeah definitely that's the goal the goal
for me has always been to start off with
the podcast the podcast is not the
end-all be-all for me it's like a
stepping stone into what I want to get
to and you brought up serious that's
where I would love to see myself I'd
love to take the podcast build a
listenership so that when I do get on
some kind of major platform I have some
people with me so that's not just a
brand new show that will have no
listeners I already have some people
there
you're way ahead of me even like already
but if what I would say man is I I think
that's a mistake I think like the
podcast is is where like you've been
doing like you've been doing it I'm not
saying you can't do that other stuff you
can still do the series
and give them both two different flavors
absolutely and maybe make the guys like
me on the podcast
I'm serious you'll have more of a if you
if you're living in La you'll have more
available guests and it can be in person
and your podcast will Skyrocket when you
get here
you know how many shows do you go to a
week
at this point it's like at least one
show a week it's like four five six
shows a month and who was the last show
you went to see the last one was Slayer
and I was up in the photo pit with
Carrie King up there come on I was
what's that come on
it was crazy I mean I I feel very very
lucky I don't take any of this for
granted you know I know there's people
that would you know Rock Fans that would
kill for this opportunity and I'm one of
them
now what about school what do you do at
school now what time do you have to be
in the morning
uh you know what I've been uh actually
taken a little Hiatus there I'm looking
at online courses and such I'm just not
the kind of guy that can get up at six
in the morning and go to and and go do
something like that that I'm not
necessarily interested in however I am
still interested in of course finishing
my education and taking it you know
obviously getting my diploma and stuff
so we're looking at a new way around it
I guess you could call it so this would
this would typically be your senior year
correct
yeah okay so you just took the senior
year off sort of like I did
yeah I took you know I found something
in August
and it filled voids and I said you know
what uh as much as it hurts me I gotta
drop out for a little while just to get
some wind under my feet
and I eventually went back and
eventually I got the diploma but
uh no you're doing the right thing then
but if you've got a job at six in the
morning you get up at six correct of
course okay don't worry if I was if
serious is calling me at 6am saying hey
we want you down here I'll be there at
5am and what kind of serious show would
you have would it be music comedians
everything the whole [__] can Bang
Yeah I see these shows that are kind of
separated into different categories and
such and that doesn't really work with
me I want to talk about
I want to play a Nas song and then I
want to play a song by Aerosmith and
then I want to play a song by you know
ASAP Rocky or whoever I want to I want
to mix it all up and then I want to you
know maybe interview an astronaut in an
interview a comic I just want to do it
all I would love to see you like on VH1
or something doing your thing
you know even VH1 is for all the [__]
like me maybe they should put you on MTV
where you [__] belong everything can
put me anywhere they want yeah mpv's
threatening to go back to music correct
well I think so I think they are and and
they should they should they are and
whatever the [__] so I mean you'd be the
guy to lead them into the next [__]
world
well I that's a really nice thing to say
yeah no listen man I watch you uh
there's two guys who really know music
in my John Wolf is good with music for
the wolf yeah Bobby Sharon's good with
music you're very good with music thank
you I see that you're right listen man
when I was 16 15 I was out I was out
going I was going well every night you
know when I went to see James Brown I
went to see The B-52s you know I went to
see Pat Benatar when most guys would go
you're a [__] [__] how can you go see
that I love the music I'd go see a
Spanish band I'd go I didn't give a [__]
I'm gonna cry I just wanted to get
inspired I remember the first time
people would say to him I can't believe
you went to see Judas Priest he's gay I
didn't give a [__] you think if you saw
him sing and do his thing Jen did this
it disappeared I didn't give a [__] what
he was no of course but uh
you lucky man you live in this [__]
life that most people dream of you're
not doing drugs you're not drinking
you're not you know hurting nobody and
uh
you're way ahead of the curve my friend
I'm trying to stay there and I you know
the kind words really mean a lot I mean
I I just I couldn't appreciate it no no
no no no give me I wanted to really know
your review on the last couple shows
you've gone to see and uh
I could tell by everything Sabbath
really blew away blew you away
absolutely it was it was like the second
that curtain dropped they opened up with
the first song Black Sabbath and it was
just you know Ozzy wasn't just seeing
those guys I mean these guys don't have
to be there doing this this is why it
matters so much to me is that these guys
have known each other since they were
like what my age back in the 60s and
they're up here jumping up and down
in their 60s you know he should be at
home in the jacuzzi with Sharon right
now he doesn't have to be here
and it's just it's it's I'm so lucky to
be able to have my generation and the
people that are my age that still enjoy
this music get to experience it still
it's unbelievable how did uh
I hear the music is [__] phenomenal I
hear them what I've seen on YouTube what
I've watched uh the shows from Chicago
people have been posting shows and just
what I've seen on YouTube is [__]
mind-boggling
the sound is just to the T and right now
I gotta be honest with you I'm on the
fence right now because I always feel
like I'm too old to be at one of those
shows but at the same time I'm not
[__] dead yet no and I'm the type of
guy that I've been looking online how
about I'll pay for those [__] tickets
well you don't have to stand in the mosh
pit and like like go crazy but you can
go and enjoy yourself listen
exactly you
someday cash is more is going to be 50.
and he's going to think of this story
and I don't know cash is a nice kid he's
he's up every day he's posting he's
doing podcasts he's interviewing people
he loves kiss and he goes after him like
a [__] Savage you know I read that
you're at the hotel and you heard Ozzy
at the hotel I mean you don't stop
that's Relentless you're like the
[__] kid from uh that movie you like
that kid living that [__] dream one
minute he's in San Diego interviewing
the school newspaper and next minute
he's on the road with [__] Led
Zeppelin and [__] uh whatever the
[__] guys almost famous Almost Famous
but at the same time you're seeing these
you know when I was your age I saw a
Sabbath for the first time
man in their Prime too
19 so no they were done
oh really they were done they were done
technical ecstasy tour or something no
that would say die
yeah it started to go downhill
I had been hearing about this band I had
probably three of two of their albums I
had paranoid
I had a sabotage
and I had bought Master reality but I
can't lie to you it was still a little
too dark for Uncle Joey she didn't want
to go into the voyage I didn't want to
go into the void just yet and that must
have been I went over with like three
kids from high school but when I got
over to the Garden there must have been
I must have counted 40 kids from my high
school yeah and it was I've seen these
mine everybody was [__] up we were all
hunting masculine and you know we had
met at five o'clock and smoked 40 joints
and you know 24 Budweisers yeah oh my
mind and those days it was nips I wasn't
a big drink I would get dizzy and pass
out so I had to like cop my beers I'd
buy an eight pack but drink four like
three and a half and dump the other ones
and [__] but I just remember going to
watch the first band who was Van Halen
man and in those days you didn't go to
watch the [__] opening band you
just didn't you just didn't most people
still don't but now people were like Van
Halen and we went and it was this
[__] crazy guy this other guy jumping
up and down but they got you and then
Black Sabbath came on and I can't tell
you how oval at that time my mom was
still alive I was still doing my game I
was having a good time they were just
the sound was horrific
Ozzy was off key he was fat as [__] he
had the big beard at that point he was
fat as [__] I don't remember if he had a
beard he was fat as [__] he's happy he
was drunk Naomi was angered about
something but the the the the the the
tie of the night was you know like and I
kind of remembered and then somebody
reminded me seeing Bill Ward snorting
off the drums oh man like I had never
saw that and I was on like after that
years later somebody I think Timmy
mentioned it to me he goes remember
Bill's Ward snorting off and I still
remember where I was I was an aside but
by the fourth song you would hear him
like guitar things going wrong like e
and all that [__] really and you could
just tell it was just Ozzy wasn't happy
I think they sang Junior's eyes and he
didn't like it he goes this is a [__]
jazz song or some [__] you know I was
just what did that do to you as a fan
them sucking so bad it wasn't that they
sucked so bad like I thought I thought
it was sucked real bad when I saw him
the first time Aerosmith like I expected
something out of this world and three
junkies came out with two other guys and
they just were going through it was like
a high school band like
you just heard different things the
Highlight was when Joe Perry broke the
guitar and people went crazy that was it
like and I went to see Ted was great
that was my first concert Ted I went to
see the stones at your age from uh the
some girls tour they were unbelievable
far and open for them they were
unbelievable I had gone to see the new
barbarians which were the stones without
Mick Jagger they were phenomenal great
experience all around and all of a
sudden I go see Black Sabbath who I had
heard so much about like I said I had
three of their albums I really didn't
know the whole catalog and they were
mediocre
right but it didn't matter I went home
and bought Never say die and I bought
technical ecstasy and I bought Sabbath
Bloody Sabbath and now and they took me
out of a dark place like when I think of
Black Sabbath like when I play sabot
Bloody Sabbath on a Monday morning that
means I'm going to war [__] this week
like that's just that that's it like
there's no smile yeah it's a big dick in
the smile Jack when I put Sabbath bunny
Sabaton on a Monday morning that means
you better be on your best behavior you
better get the knife ready because
that's what that means you're going to
war and you're not sick of any of these
songs by now none of these songs did you
see my excitement tonight when I was
listening to Children of the Grave and
Fairies Wear boots
it was just as exciting for me so when I
see Cassius saying that he was at a
[__] hotel and he heard [__]
Ozzie's voice
that Jesus Christ what do you think I
[__] feel like I feel like an [__]
I felt like an [__] because it turned
out he was sick that day and he actually
canceled the show so I didn't want to
bother him but it was crazy though did
they redo the show there did they did
they did a month later they came back I
went I drove three hours to Calgary to
see the one show saw the other show here
both were worth it and you mentioned
children Children of the Grave I will
tell you that's the best song that's the
song to see if you're going to see them
don't miss that one because they got
fireworks Aussie's jumping up and down
it's it's insane he's jumping up and
down he gets on his hands and knees he's
bow into the audience the guy's like 70.
you know it does something it doesn't it
it really does it does I thought I I'm
like I'm like I'm not gonna go see that
old man Fest and I'm like wait a second
They carried me through the darkest
times of my [__] life how am I gonna
go pay my [__] respects you know how
many hits of acid I did the Black
Sabbath sabotage to bring me back from
you know uh old man what other songs did
they play I thought really I'm not gonna
lie to you
one of the songs I looked up their set
list it is [__] phenomenal you're
such a bad nerd for music get the
setlist Lee
2016 Black Sabbath tour at setlist let's
go over it with Cassius because this is
my little [__] brother who knows
what's crack I got more trust in you
cash this than half these [__] music
craze they don't know dick I want to
give a shout out to my main man Mike at
the jewelry store in Union City New
Jersey saying not to forget [__] uh
Mandy Johnson and uh David rivers and uh
nah nah nah we had a bunch of Nikki
gallis and we had a ton of [__]
players in HQ and HC what the [__] HQ
like a man
Cassius Morris you got new trucks what
do you got up there in the Calgary you
got some stars of death what do you got
stars of death we got numbers we got
hash good good but you got everything
we're all set but you're a nice boy you
don't know nothing you don't do nothing
you haven't talked to nobody in years
I don't play games man I I just I I do
what I got to do and uh I stay in my
Lane I try not to bother anybody like
you said and I do what I can I do it I
want your friends how are your friends
how come your friends ain't there with
long ham
they come around they're good they're
good I actually um it's funny because
there are a lot of them are rocking
metal fans so I get to be like yeah this
is my camera guy let him backstage and
they'll let the let them back into the
tour bus and stuff it's it's been great
I get to give away concert tickets all
the time to my buddies you know they
love it let me ask you this what albums
are you listening to this week what have
you been listening to since Monday talk
to me oh man let me tell you talk to me
baby Bloody Sabbath Bloody Sabbath and
the first time I heard this was on your
show when you played a national acrobat
you pushed me over the edge
every day if you think that you know
what national acrobat did to me are you
[__] kidding me
and the world that hides the universal
secret of the time yeah are you [__]
kidding me who writes that [__] who
writes that what did you drink to write
that you just don't get up in the
morning and say I am the world that
hides the universal secret of all time
you just don't come up with me Geezer
was a Madman oh my God oh my God
killing yourself to live oh I'm a
sabotage guy too a dog megalomania I
almost jumped off a building the thrill
of it all when I put the thrill of it
all on that means not only am I going to
war but I'm stabbing somebody I got the
knife I got the [__] Windex I gotta
everybody no we're stabbing everybody
hit me with the set list all right from
the beginning read it all down here for
your Uncle Joey right so this is for the
one at Madison Square Garden uh
February 27th
so they open with Black Sabbath
Fairies Wear Boots damn we had that on
tonight
after forever oh [__] have you ever
thought about your soul can it be saved
or perhaps you think that when you are
dead
you just stay in the grave come on now
what else we got into the void Jesus
Christ oh my God into the void I'm gonna
have to bring a gun there and just shoot
myself in the eyeball what I do when I
put a void just to end it just like a
gentleman just go home after that
well you can't go home after that
because then there's snow blind what oh
Jesus Christ yep and then they go right
into War Pigs all right and then behind
the wall of sleep
did you get that up there got everything
got everything come on I couldn't
believe it and I don't know what this
means but with rasp intro if you know
what that is the Geezer Butler baseball
yeah go ahead what else
nib all right it was basically intro oh
[__]
uh Hand of Doom
yeah now that one changed my life that
one changed my life too the lyrics on
that one especially when you're tripping
never mind when they're like when you're
just talking to your friends and
giggling
it's when you put it on and you're
getting home from a long night and you
think you're down from the acid you put
that almond and you dim the lights
you don't know who shows up right next
to you and starts asking a creepy
question
what else is on there uh Rat salad oh
Jesus Christ with a drum solo Jesus
Christ
it was good it was no very good and then
there's Iron Man dirty woman
and Children of the Grave and then the
Encore was paranoid
let me tell you something what's the
what's the do the last five again okay
including the Encore now no no no just
the last five from the top right not
from the top right there Children of the
Grave yeah dirty woman yeah Iron Man let
me tell you something
the guitar solo on dirty women
tell these [__] out doesn't he
have four missing fingers the top the
tips oh yeah he cut him off in a sheep
metal Accent on his last day there you
go
his last day ever what did he do he
turned the cords upside down he did
something he did something Jimi Hendrix
he put bass chords on a guitar to give
it a thicker sound it just this is the
type of [__] that you don't know
but when a guy like me thinks about it
it thinks how [__] ignorant I am but
this guy said you know what wait a
second what kind of [__] can I put on
this to create my own sound so I don't
sound like everybody else you know as as
Cassius and I know when I hear Ace
Freely I know it's [__] Ace
Frehley oh yeah he's a badass
[__] Tony iomi I know it's ioman when
I hear Gilmore I know it's [__] David
Gilmore because that's what they did
they devised their own sound when I hear
Clapton I know what type that I know it
when I hear Keith Richards I know it
they are who they are because when I
hear Stevie Vine what toys are you
looking to come to town what are you
looking at what shows are you [__]
hoping come in so you can rock them out
who's coming up I want to see kiss again
it's been a while man but the number one
I want to see
I mean I I honestly I can't even ask for
anything I mean I've seen everything
that I've wanted to see I've seen
everybody there is I mean once you see
Ozzy two days in a row it's all over
where are you gonna go from there
I love your attitude all right I love
you I love your attitude who's coming up
there the next couple weeks I know that
there's some uh who's Stevie Vai he put
together a band that's smoking really I
didn't hear about it yet somebody was
two guys and a badass singer
hey man I tell you who's on the road you
should go see him just out of respect
because I know you appreciate this [__]
bad company and Joe Walsh I heard you
talking about that saying it was going
to be a great show listen that could go
two ways that could be like a Ringo
Starr and Friends reunion but you want
to just commit suicide that's where they
invented the Punta Jim Jones drink at
the island was that the Ringo Star
concert they're like listen we gotta
make some suicide juice and get it the
Ringo
finally so [__] uh
but it could also be like listen I know
Bad Company
is going to knock your pants off uh of
course they've got I haven't found them
at Atomic records you know desolation
Angels uh
Bad Company Bad Company is a classic
album but there's one of them
burning sky
or the sky is burnt but yeah something
like that that's a [__] masterful
that's a great band they were so good
they were on the Led Zeppelin label they
were managed by Peter Grant
a lot of people don't know that oh they
do know that they don't give a
Frenchman's [__] but if you don't know
now you [__] know you know what I'm
saying [__] that guy is a pimp
that guy and the singer from that has a
wig he got thrown out the first time for
kicking the guy in the mountain he's a
black belt in karate but he was also
thought to replace Jim Morrison when he
died Paul Rogers was the only
replacement they had in mind when Jim
Morrison died he went on to sing with a
band called free and then he went on to
Bad Company
who in my world you know listen the
proof isn't the [__] pudding put on
the four [__] albums and get back to
me [__]
so call me later call me later [__] you
know what I'm saying welcome to my world
[__]
so when are we gonna sing it down here
my brother talk to me tell me about your
plans what do we need to put together do
we need to put together a GoFundMe
Cassius Morris moving party to Hollywood
and ball lick once you get here over at
the rainbow we'll sit you down in
Lemmy's chair and we'll have some chick
lick your nuts or whatever that's I mean
throwing some [__] Heat tonight in a
podcast I'll be out there I'll be out
there hopefully in September I want to
catch that show at the bowl I've got and
I I'd love to see you guys if you guys
are around say hello something you know
man I'll tell you what I have been on
the fence when I get back on Sunday I'm
going to go online and start
investigating these tickets and I'm
gonna try to get some tickets and I'm
gonna try to hook up with you there I
think it's time of course to go I mean
these guys are my childhood why not go
and pay my last respects I don't give a
[__] what they want for a ticket at this
point you know it's not too bad no it's
not too bad I have a an account I have
on the side that my wife don't even know
about nobody knows about it's in last
year when they would pay me with cash
sometimes they would give me bills I
would put those 200 bills away or a
hundred dollar bill if somebody would
give me a 50. I would put that 50 Bill
away while I look the other day Jesus I
got like 600 bucks and then 50s you know
what I'm saying so I'm gonna you're all
prepared yeah I'm gonna use that for my
little Black Sabbath stash and take an
Uber to the Hollywood Bowl so I have to
walk up that [__] Hill yeah you know
walking up the hill is [__] up walking
down with a hit of acid in me I'll walk
through your [__] Calgary
walk all the way to Canada past the the
Secret Service so what else is going on
let us know what we're gonna see from
Cassius the next few weeks you're
writing a Blog what are you doing what
are you doing you writing lots of uh
lots of concert reviews I actually have
a Black Sabbath sabotage podcast coming
up we go track by track through the uh
through the whole album talk about you
know each song
um I'm I've got Iron Maiden coming up in
just over a week and I'm hoping to get
the photo pass for that and just lots of
music podcasts and Hip Hop too I'm
actually a lot of people don't know I'm
a huge hip-hop guy so how far back do
you go
way back I I you know biggie Nas AZ
everybody how great is [__] Nas
the best I just saw him actually no you
did not front row and how good was he
live
it was incredible he came over pointed
at me said the World is Yours he killed
it and it was an outside in a hail storm
I forgot it was hailing
you my friend have uh a great future
ahead of you I wish you nothing but
great things
I sit there and look at your post and I
admire you
because I wish I would have fell in love
how you did my life would have been a
lot different I wouldn't got tangled up
with drugs and the [__] I would have
done what my love was which was what you
have on your walls that was those were
my walls right there those are my walls
I'd Kiss Alive on there I had [__]
The Beatles White Album on there I had
dark side of the moon on my wall to this
day Kiss Alive I take I told these guys
why I don't listen to it because me and
my boy Anthony balzano used to listen to
it when he died I put the album in his
casket and I said the next time we
listen to it
is where the [__] they said you because
wherever you're going I'll be there
[__] you know what I'm saying
Heaven hell Purgatory or dump [__]
Jersey somewhere I'll be there with that
album so whatever you want to call it my
brother I'm happy you [__] called in
tonight thank you very much you're uh
you're an inspiration you're a bad
[__] with a great future
anything I can do for you please reach
thank you so much Uncle Joey and thank
you to all the church people that have
been hitting me up on Twitter and online
you guys are the best and Lee thank you
too so much what are you gonna listen to
tonight drop drop it out what are you
doing tonight what's your schedule look
like on a Wednesday night
it's nine o'clock over there so you're
in for the night couple numbers a little
bit of Metallica some Sublime
uh I got some Alice Cooper lined up for
tonight but a rush
yeah I [__] love you kidding keep
doing what you're doing you need
something you call us all right brother
thank you thank you very much thank you
an inspiration brother by the way thank
you that was you guys take care thank
you you too my friend
what do you think about that Lee it was
great and you want to stay in on the
[__] weekends and get no sunshine
that's it no more of that [__] no more
than [__] no more that's it I don't care
we gotta put a [__] hat on
what nothing I'm no I'm just it started
to hit me during that I know that was
like he's great we I had him on my
podcast to talk about his podcasting
that kid is a great kid and uh
Jesus you know you think of all the
directions you could go to a kid like
that at that age right that those are
the years those are the years
that if you fall in with one dude
you know I stole the car whatever
whatever that's it
and to see him with that head you know
thinking ahead of the game he's not
being fresh he's always respectful
well his dad's a police officer I
believe yeah no no but they watch him
they watch him they've given him Freedom
at the same time
to to do what he's wanted to do you know
30 years ago you couldn't come home and
tell your dad you would drop it out
you've seen he would smack you in the
[__] face
yeah they would call you a loser make
you join the service oh my I think it's
even newer than that because my mom if I
had tried to drop I wouldn't never have
let me but I mean he's been doing it I
think since he said he's nine or ten so
he has more experience than than I do
than most people do
you know
like I was talking about in the
beginning of the thing you know
we got into college basketball you know
that because I'm watching this
and I was saying to myself I hope
that Mercy my daughter
gets it
at an early age that this is the route
to go that the route to go is in high
school to get good grades and
pick a sport or whatever the [__] you
want to do play the flute golf
tennis whatever the [__] it is and
strive to go to a great College get a
great education but the whole thing is
to like strive like to make a mark like
to leave your name on that college wall
to do something you know I dreamed of
that I didn't give a [__] about the pros
do you think I wanted to be a pro
basketball player all I wanted to do was
step in that [__] Circle and put them
to say from North Bergen New Jersey at
[__] forward Joey Coco Diaz that that
that's it I would have a heart attack
that's it it wouldn't have mattered my
performance
it wouldn't have mattered What mattered
to me was I got to that Circle
I never got to that Circle man
that'll haunt me till I'm [__] and I
can tell you 20 excuses
the excuses was I was a [__] [__]
I gave up I let somebody beat me
you know what I'm saying and I'm and
somewhere unconsciously
I told myself I'd never let somebody
beat me again especially when I realized
what had happened at that age I didn't
comprehend what had happened ah I just
didn't like it no more that was [__]
you just don't like something no more
you just don't like uh
something that you've given your heart
into that you've run up hills that you
you know I used to ride a bike with a
basketball between my legs
you know me and that kid Sabatino that
call you know me and him been playing
well he's gonna call the podcast
next week and tell you [__]
some [__] up [__] stories I'm gonna
have him because his mother was my lunch
teacher the lady who gave me sandwiches
at the [__] lunch place
so anyway but that's what I want for my
daughter I hope she gets
the understanding that
you know that's that's what's cool
that's what's [__] cool in my world
that was the coolest [__] thing it
wasn't music
it wasn't smoking weed it wasn't you
know going to a concert in those days
none of that mattered to me I like music
and everything I put music I put Led
Zeppelin on while I was practicing
basketball but my world was that my
whole Focus was that
to go to a college after I got LED back
do you know what I felt like
a [__] [__] only retards get left
back retards get left back if you
[__] think about it you got four
quarters to make it happen
you know what I'm saying because you
might be a [__] up you might be [__]
to like January and then wake up out of
your [__] coma and score big on the
finals in March and then knock them dead
in June and squeeze out of there with a
c and [__]
they'll [__] watch you for a while
you'll spend out a couple D's your mama
make you wash some dishes but that ain't
bad enough like getting [__] left
back dog nothing stays at you like
getting left back maybe AIDS
[__] A tattoo that [__] has drilled
me since day one then dropping out of
high school are you [__] kidding me
that really shunned my [__] ego that
destroyed my insides dog quit in high
school in those days to me was what
losers did you didn't quit [__] high
school quit High School guys went on the
corners
smoke cigarettes and [__] that's who
quits high school and that's why I
became a guy who I don't want to smoke
three from those stupid [__] stories
but at least I know this going in you
find one right let's give some shout
outs here Chris James 1978
Shea 7 roj Andrew then dial up there in
Nyack New York waiting for me up there
in [__] November we're gonna be
freezing like do [__] morons Lauren
rosenker my main man my heart always
brother I got you Josh Chambers Gary
Warden Bobby Sharon [__] music
empresario and [__] down there in
[__] Austin Texas selling T-shirts
and [__] bubble gums he don't give a
[__] Bobby Sharon and Donovan salaruzzo
this [__] sour up there doing
Jiu Jitsu somewhere [__] choking
somebody what do you have to say for
yourself [__]
I I'm I'm doing good man I'm just really
enjoying this [__] star death
Stars
[__] sucker where you going this weekend
this weekend uh I have to go Paula's
having like an event for her law school
so I have to go get a suit I haven't put
a suit on forever did you buy a suit yet
no I well I have a suit but it was like
when I was super fat so it's looking
take it in which it felt nice you gotta
take it in I had to well why don't you
go get a nice new suit because I'm still
trying to lose weight but you gotta win
a nice shoe go down to Hollywood [__]
shoot down there no this is a nice suit
but listen to me you it's old it's got
dust on it's got old Jude dust in the
closet God how many times you wear it
you wore it to that [__] wedding yeah
he already worn this is Paula's [__]
gig surprise I'll get one for her
graduation no no forget the graduation
listen do we have comments on Thursday
you're not listening to me what time
Thursday
evening okay listen tomorrow morning you
wake up at 905.
you have a nice breakfast you get in the
[__] car
you got on the 134.
stop and you connect on the one-on-one
sound
gonna be about 20-25 minutes of traffic
no big [__] deal I got look
who's better than your Uncle Joey you
know who nobody okay I'm gonna save you
time I'm gonna make your day tomorrow
cause you ain't doing deck tomorrow in
the daytime and and and
you're gonna make a world
because you took the time to do it she's
expecting you to Win It suit
which he will bust in there looking like
[__] Jimmy De Leon 155th Street what
are you nuts are you [__] nuts don't
worry about Jimmy Dalia but the boot
you're gonna put you got a yamaka hit
with you you got a yamaker of course
at that [__] Jew school it's a law
school what do you think goes to law
school Armenian Mexican-American law
association dinners who gives a [__]
this gotta be a junior and you're gonna
connect with them bam just like that bam
you're gonna make eye contact when
you're gonna listen the only reason why
we is for an envelope
some in this [__] room we're gonna
get an envelope
so listen to what you're gonna do
because I love you to death like a
nephew if you need the deuce I'll give
you the deuce because I love you
you're like I'm a 134 at nine o'clock
you're gonna get to Hollywood about 9
35. all right
you're gonna go to the Hollywood Suit
Outlet
you're gonna park your car right in
front of the spot because there's a
there's parking right there
you're gonna be there bright and early
with those [__] Savages open up the
gate okay you're a Jew all right if
you're gonna do business what's the
matter or Nothing what felt something
felt you keep looking at the computer
like it's the end of the world like I'm
gonna [__]
like I'm on Norad or something I thought
I heard something but we're cool you
don't hear nothing
you're [__] me up my Kramer party I'm
setting you up tomorrow I'm hooking you
up big time I'm not a Hollywood you're
at the Hollywood shootout you're just
not at the Hollywood student let's see
these are foreigners these are those
Israelis we spoke about
those dark-skinned [__] with
the black feet you could a needle won't
even go in their [__] skin they're
those little mountain Brothers they got
up there in Israel
they're there they got a couple
Armenians listen they don't want to lose
the first goal of the day
it's bad luck you're the first goal of
the day okay so you're going in there
with two bills in your [__] hand and
you're gonna go listen I'm looking for
three suit deal
okay you gotta go in there you're gonna
pick out three suits for 200 with a
shirt
and a pair of socks the socks you can
light them on fire they're polyester the
[__] you might as well like that on fire
too but what you're gonna do is bro
you're gonna take the shirt and that's
gonna be your alternative shirt like
when you got to do something stupid and
you think you have to take the jacket
off and there's been people smoking pot
I take those shirts home those are
utility white shirts get a gray shirt
because they give you three suits three
shirts and a belt
for the small deuce
and they trick you because if you go to
the big six hundred dollar suits it's
the same two and on the suits the guy
who used to work there he went somewhere
else and he told me he goes when you go
in there just get the two other suits
double ultimate for you while they're
altering them for you in the back
whatever it is the small 35 whatever it
is Lee get a pair of shoes nice
and while they're fixing your suits you
know what you're gonna do what you're
gonna go to the fruit juice stand and
get a little sandwich for eight dollars
and fifty fans now you're saying but
Joey
why do I need to be suitable because the
number one suit you're gonna bust out
tomorrow night the number two suit
you're gonna bust out at the graduation
and the number three suit is when you go
away with it to some other [__]
events usually go Lee who the [__] are
you John Gotti
and he's just not you're gonna get a
nice double-breasted [__] suit you
know what I'm saying
and it's a utility suit Lee it's not
like you're dropping 500 for a suit and
you're gonna lose 15 20 pounds and you
look like a [__] moot these are
throwaway suits believe me these suits
are bust them out two times and one
night I go to fart in the pants rip and
I throw them right away they're no big
[__] deal they cost you what 66
dollars a suit
so you really have no stock in them but
you got them in the closet you look
sharp and guess what she's gonna expect
for you to show up tomorrow looking like
Lee you're gonna bust out with a nice
jacket and a nice pink shirt something
to stand out with the Mexicans man who's
that handsome little Jew with you a pink
shirt whatever you gotta stand out you
can't go in there with a white shirt
looking like the rest of those [__]
mutts
right or wrong if not they're gonna go
who's this [__] mother he talks about
gluten he works on the podcast who gives
a [__] you're gonna go out with them
you're the Jew in the house that
Mexicans wanted to be a Jew
you're a Jew they all want to be
attorneys right or wrong what the [__]
we're talking about the apples and
potatoes well
absolutely yeah they just all around you
you're gonna spend 300 you're gonna make
a world
you're gonna look sharp you're gonna get
a fruit smoothie with a [__] chicken
salad sandwich with an avocado on it
who's better than you I like 10 in the
morning Shuffle gives a [__] 10 in the
morning you're gonna get up tomorrow you
still got some of that weed left at the
house right oh yeah so you can bang out
two little hits you don't commit because
if you're eating an edible that's a big
commitment by one o'clock your eyes are
spinning yet like they're spinning now
but if you take two little bangers on
the balcony
you're getting the [__] car you go
down by the time you get down there by
the time the suit's getting altered you
walk a block and a half you put two more
quarters in the meter
it's two-hour parking you walk a block
and a half you sit with the [__]
Spanish people from El Salvador
you get yourself the sandwich and the
smoothie and then you walk back who's
better than you and the ultra right
there and you'll be right in the back
like a doctor these are listen these are
not okey-doke people these people are
prepared for war they want every dollar
in your pocket
okay you only give them the small deuce
you follow me
so yeah and then you're in your car by
12. you're back over the hill with the
new shoes three suits three shirts and
two o'clock you're in front of your
[__] Nintendo preparing your speech
yeah
I've never I ugly I've started to like
lose some of the belly so it should look
a little bit better sure with a [__]
shirt now you look like John Gotti what
are you [__] nuts we gotta get you a
little rug you know what I'm saying like
I need a rug
just a little tube to win emergency
situations you know what I'm saying
do you know people who wear toupees I
don't know them per listen I couldn't
have a friend that wore Tupac
I gotta have a talk you would have to
grab it like if you ever said no it's
okay you have to play with that's
disrespectful you can't grab somebody's
[__] poop
but you could talk you know no no no no
I've never had a friend that attitude I
dated a girl that a father was the king
of the wigs he'd bust out different wigs
and he had to look at him and make
believe like you know
you want to eat a [__] he's got a nice
hand too you know what I'm saying with
it I want you to tell her your father's
got a [__] up bad dude that's it no
more sucking sucking
[Music]
what kind of wigs would you wear like
women's wigs no like men's wigs but he
[__] lost like the middle like he had
the sides but some wigs he would win it
looked like George Jetson some ways he'd
wear and they'd have like a Dippity dupe
he had like two or three different wings
the thing is they come out and they
think like you don't know
like you're playing a [__] joke on me
like I don't know you have a [__] wig
on if I put a wig on I go somewhere like
deep like Michael Jackson's deep
like Michael Jackson had a wig
that was all a [__] wig I didn't know
that till I watched autopsy a couple
weeks ago so you guys gotta stop
watching autopsy that's the show on real
TV
they got everything they had Jimi
Hendrix dying on there what happened to
him they had what happened to Jim
Morrison they reopened up the caskets
everything
do you know people are getting beard
transplants now
because like some hipsters are on
unsatisfied with their beard so it's
like an actual medical procedure
so what do you do I think I think they
probably do the same thing like they do
for like uh like they take it from the
back of the head maybe I don't know how
to do the research but
it's uh it's an actual medical procedure
let me tell you something
I'm not gonna lie nobody here
when I was a kid
I played football in the eighth grade
just to get in shape
I had to put tape on my [__] legs
they told me how to shave my legs I
shaved my head my legs not my head never
came back
I'm not a hairy guy at all I got like
three or four my hat my ass is hairy I
got a cup I got a patch of hand in my
left shoulder but besides that I got no
hair on my back
I just started getting here heading out
at 50. I'm not a [__] hairy guy but I
gotta tell you something
I couldn't [__] grow beard
never if I wanted to
I don't think it grew up how long you
know me it would take me a month to get
what you have on your face right now
yeah I think that's normal no
I did you shaved three days you look
like some [__] burglar I don't shave
a [__] week I get three little
[__] cat heads
how long did it take you for the garage
match
to grow that a month
wow yeah that's low a month I have no
hair
so I get it this is going the hairdo is
going any day now look at it it's going
it's I don't give a [__] that's fine I
don't give a [__] I don't give a [__]
it's one me good listen I'm lucky at a
lot of guys but if I was bald early on I
wouldn't have you're great you you
accepted it when I had that conversation
with you three years ago you were like
what I was born in high school I knew
what I knew what my fate was you weren't
gonna did you at any time think about
wearing a wig was there any depression
in your life no at all no no I'm not
gonna get girls nothing no no no well I
mean maybe that but that's I didn't have
any control over it so that's that's
something I did you use brofish in the
beginning yeah when I was young did they
give a prescription for it yeah but then
they found out that it kills your
libidos that it took me off it and it's
kind of expensive and I tried the
Rogaine I tried everything but what's
the real game uh I've done foam I've
done they have drops they're supposed to
put on your scalp a few times a day but
no one can remember to do it like I just
and it did of course it doesn't work or
I just it I love doing this now it's not
like something like I have to just get
be better about shaving like every other
day because sometimes it gets too long
but this is great and you're shaving the
shower with the Steam on no I shower and
then I get out and shave what are you
[__] what do you mean no you shave
in the shower get yourself a [__]
mirror
it doesn't fog up okay okay and when you
shave you want your pores to be [__]
open yeah so you throw that hot water in
your [__] head you're in there for a
little while right you go in the [__]
shower right right and you take the the
[__] shampoo first and you wash your
hair and then that washes the [__]
elements and it goes into your [__]
body then you take your [__]
toothbrush and you brush your teeth
really [__] good in the shower [__]
yeah the water what toothpaste on your
toes I've come on my toes what
toothpaste gonna do what's wrong well
you have again just standing at the sink
because what do I want to get out for
why am I going to burn water two times
I'm in there already let me bathe on
everything so I just [__] hit those
Tetons in the [__] everything
above the back when I'm out there I just
do light brushes when I'm in the shower
I [__] take that stick I brush the
back of my tongue I almost choke I [__]
in the tongue everything
then that comes out then I get the
[__] condition I put that in my hair
then I get the loofah and I put the soap
on the Loof and I loofah [__]
everything to get all those dead
molecules and all that dead [__] got
skin off I'm sweating Coke from 1980
[__] four and chemicals and and fat
and [__] chicken sandwiches whatever
the [__] I eat all those years and right
now your pores are open
you open it so right there boom you take
that shaving cream
and you wipe it you put it all over your
[__] head you don't need a mirror
what mirror do you need right here you
just put like that
and then you just go to town you don't
even need a mirror you just go back with
the heat on the hot water is hitting
your hair your pores are opening up
you get a little soap and some Irish
Spring you put a little polish in that
[__] what I mean
you come out you dry that little
[__] nice you put a little
[__] Greek grease on it or something
whatever the [__] you got to shine it up
with some cream right you put a little
cream on your head so you have to shave
on your head dude who's better than you
but why are you going to come out of the
shower dry yourself and go through the
process again I don't dry my head I go I
literally get out just doesn't jump we
gotta dry your head because the shaving
cream won't attack the [__] hair
follicles
it's Edge rise
I don't know I'm [__] what is wrong
with you it works I don't know I don't
know maybe I'm doing wrong the shower
it's one movement that's it when you
come out of the shower you're done you
brush your teeth you wash your [__]
you shaved your head you [__] took
the dead man out of your eyeballs
everything one shot bam you come out you
stick this in your [__] nose I had to
break it I got these white hairs in my
nose and all this [__]
spray and steroids they gave me to spray
my [__] nose so now it's like I got
blow around my nose people looking at me
weird like I'm doing bumps
why are you looking at me with [__] that
second
I
I've never thought about doing anything
like I know people do it but I I don't
know I just started sharing the shower
10 years ago I'm no genius I'm a [__]
[__] somebody told me once they saw I
was cut and they go why do you shave
you're [__] shave in the shower with
the hot water it opens up your pores it
slides right through with some nice
shaving cream
and you know yeah one of those uh no fog
mirrors and they really fog up it's a
scam but you just work with it
okay all those no foggy mirrors that
piece of [__] I had a radio once it blew
up what the [__] it was like one of
those skateboards those black dudes on
skateboards they always blowing
all those things called the uh the
hoverboards yeah they're made by the KKK
those [__] things have you seen the
videos of them blowing up oh please if
black people always flying through the
[__] damn my shoes are on fire
those hoverboards a KKK propaganda dog
that's what those [__] Things Are hmm
unfucking believable people blowing up
to these idiots driving down the street
like this is on fire people going on
Jews on fire Jews on fire people going
on fire in their houses that's the only
one with the chicken over but did you
watch the tape the other day of the high
school band or something
the dude the magician with the wand
ER
no what happened
I'm watching this those thing the other
night
Stone to the gills I ain't bothering
nobody I'm sitting there also like an
eyewitness news an explosion in the high
school or something like that it was
like a pep rally and some dude was out
there with sticks with fire and it hit
some and it blew up and all of a sudden
you see some kid just go
and just fly up and he was on a
on a on a [__] trampoline or whatever
the [__] that was
Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ that's the best thing you
got to tell me I had a nice time with
you tonight it was nice to see you it's
going to be [__] Easter this weekend
Steve Simone's making a lasagna he's
back from China oh yeah he had a great
time I didn't talk to him he's a little
sick he brought back to the Chinese flu
so if you see him you don't want to talk
to him time you're busy till Tuesday
comes to go drink some soy sauce or
something get that [__] out of this
[__] system he brought that Chinese
food back that [__] will never go away
that's why they walk around with the
masks over there oh [__] I I didn't know
so when he comes in here you gotta
[__] spray everything down and you
know
wear like a repellent keep the door open
put them by the door
don't let the espirit those models get
in here on Sunday you know what I'm
saying you gotta watch them get some
Lysol spread save the receipt okay
because if not we'll be getting that
Chinese [__] flu next thing you know
you know I'm gonna [__] in the hospital
there coughing and [__] nobody knows
what's wrong with me you know what I'm
saying that's [__] up
the Chinese flew that's scary who the
[__] knows Lake you know I don't know if
it's a Chinese food he called he could
have caught on the plane in Newark I'm
just saying he was in China right and he
came back and he got the flu what is
that what are your cues
who do you accuse
probably the Chinese okay then then what
are you sitting there looking at me like
you don't know what the [__] I'm talking
about you know what I'm talking about
[__] listen man
I got this company they call me up with
different [__] things you know half
the things I tell them I don't like what
I'm doing yeah guys come on I don't want
to [__] this thing you know I look at
the web page I contact my attorney we
talk about it I talk to Lee you know and
we're like I don't know this is an idea
that I dig if you're a stoner do
yourself a favor and listen up okay I'm
telling you right now you got smart cars
smartphones Smart Homes Technology has
made everything smart but losing your
stuff still makes Smart people feel
really stupid I lose my [__] one time a
week whether it's keys I always know I
bring the wallet up from the car
but I put it in different places you're
following me instead of putting it in
one [__] place so I always know I
bring that wallet up with me in the car
I hold on to my wallet like a
[__] but sometimes I think it's
in the bedroom and it's in the you know
where it is in the bathroom of my
shaving kit because when I come in the
piss I put it in there and it falls in
and now I don't see it for two hours ah
tracking makes losing things a thing of
the past tracker is a coin size device
that locates missed Keys wallets bags
computers anything in seconds just bear
tracking to your smartphone attach it to
anything and find this precise location
with a tap of a button it's that easy
right you lost your phone press the
button on track and your phone rings
even if it's on silent with over 1.5
million devices tractor has the largest
crowd GPS Network in the world so you
lost your item shows up on a map even if
it's miles away never lose anything
again with trackers this is what I'm
gonna do all right listeners in the show
get a special discount of 40 off again
40 off again 40 off your first tracking
device go to the tracker.com and enter
promo code Church
c-h-u-r-c-h okay you're never gonna lose
anything again the hardest thing you'll
ever have to find is their website go to
the tracker.com right now and enter the
promo code church for forty percent off
again that's the tracker.com promo code
Church do yourself a favor you'll never
lose not like that again talk about your
ease or your wallets or
maybe an album you know what I'm saying
I don't want my album to get lost you
know we put them all over the place just
do me a favor go to vtracker.com and get
40 off your first tracking device promo
code Church c h u r c h
as usual
on it always there for me I still
haven't gotten my my Dolce new whey
protein yet I'm still waiting you
understand me it should be here by next
week so I can sample and tell you guys
what I think you know me when it comes
to almond on it I like the chocolate
hemp Force that's my protein every day
two scoops of banana four ice cubes some
water
stop it Little Hershey's syrup in there
boom not a lot of her she said just a
dab just a little sugar whatever I put a
workout yeah no just absolutely a dab of
sugar in it it's not bad for you boom
right then and there it's tremendous the
the strong bone come on the the the the
the new one the new moon they have the
new moon but you know what they have now
oh my God they have this new Alpha Brain
you got to go to the web page because I
was reading about the other day and I
didn't write anything down I'm very
sorry about that my unprofessionalism
just do me a favor go to honored.com for
the great list of supplements right now
why [__] around go down it right now and
pressing the code word church
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 off your first
order delivered to your house talking
about delivery to your house let me tell
you something all right
a couple days ago I got a box delivered
to my house they just sent it to Uncle
Joey from NatureBox this stuff was
delicious and there's nothing like
getting home and having a thing of
Nature Box on your door nothing like it
and when they send you like a surprise
pack are you [__] kidding me oh
that's amazing because sometimes you
could order what you want but sometimes
they send you stuff that you wouldn't
necessarily order but then guys like you
and me smoke a joint we break into the
bag and they're delicious they sent me
some french toast squid just delicious
type of stuff all right you're trying to
eat better
but you think nutrition labels are
confusing makeup NatureBox has a snack
for that they've taken out the guesswork
and forestation and frustration so you
could snack confidently and stop wasting
time sifting through nutrition labels
all right you're trying to restrict
brego Friday birthday cupcakes and bake
sale Betty at the off 100 ridiculous
delicious snacks and they Source from
all over the world for you to choose
from my personal favorites okay are the
Pacific plantains the sesame sticks the
uh salt and pepper lentil Loops I love
all this stuff do me a favor right
NatureBox makes it easy for you to find
the snacks you want without questioning
what's in them plus they're constantly
adding new and interesting snacks to for
you to discover NatureBox believes you
shouldn't eat something you don't like
so if you try a snack you don't like
they'll replace it on your next box fan
for free can't do that with other snacks
you know
so do me a favor go to naturebox.com Joy
right now get 50 off your first box
fifty percent off your first box of
delicious unique snacks without any
other junk that's naturebox.com slash
joy for fifty percent off your first box
of the best tasting snacks in the world
naturebox.com Joey fifty percent off
right now and guess what delivered to
your [__] door resealable packages
naturebox.com Joey right now I want to
thank one more time tracker tremendous
go over there get 40 off I want to thank
on it I also want to thank NatureBox
NatureBox I want to thank my main man
Cassius Morris I'm also letting you
[__] know right up straight up
and personal next Thursday Friday
Saturday boy improv Leo be there
Thursday night Tommy East will be that
Johnny Rock will be there we got a jack
I said dulliano be there that [__]
he's bringing the Armenians so don't
[__] around if you need a Lexus come on
down [__] suckers beside that uh I love
you guys with all my heart I'm also
going to be in Indianapolis and buffalo
and [__] April so that's it that's
all I gotta tell you [__] have
a great weekend and we'll be back Monday
night all right I want to thank tractor
NatureBox and on it one more time and my
little brother Lee Syed for making this
all possible